if you've ever used a static rouse to
define how traffic should move between
private networks then you probably know
how vulnerable it is to things like
component failures or the wind or
squirrels and this episode of cloud
networking I'll show you how to leverage
cloud router to create dynamic routing
and not have to worry about cute fuzzy
networking hazards
[Music]
imagine you have a V PC setup with
multiple VMs in a subnet hbm's traffic
is directed through static routes to a
cloud VPN gateway encrypting traffic to
and from your on-premise network this is
fine as long as your on-prem network has
a firewall and router which know how to
send traffic to your cloud VPN gateway
now what happens if you have two
networks on-premise this would require
you to manually add static routes in
google cloud that expand each VMs
routing table to include new network
paths on-premise and you need to
reconfigure your VPN on both ends which
causes it to drop and re-establish this
isn't exactly fun especially for larger
organizations who turn up new testing
networks several times a week or more
static routes in this case can be
painful for a number of reasons
a topology change on either network
requires you to manually update static
routes also static routes can't
automatically reroute traffic if a link
fails what we want is a solution where
our networks can automatically and
rapidly discover topology changes and
then route traffic accordingly so our
users don't sense disruptions this is
exactly what dynamic routing does which
Google cloud platform offers as cloud
router now if a link fails cloud router
can automatically reroute traffic if
another path is possible it works like
this when you extend your on-prem
network to Google cloud cloud router
peers with your on-prem VPN gateway or
router the routers exchange topology
information through border gateway
protocol bgp cloud router advertises
semanas from its VPC network to the
on-premise gateway via bgp then topology
changes automatically propagate between
your VPC and on-prem network a great
side effect can be lower latency because
cloud router learns the
premise routes through bgp and let's the
network infrastructure pick the best
route to reach the destination if you're
using cloud router with VPN it frees you
from management headache for a number of
reasons you don't need to statically
manage subnets like adding and removing
static routes for your VPN it scales
with your traffic because it's not a
physical device that might cause a
bottleneck and the bgp session informs
each router of local changes meaning any
new subnets you add are seamlessly
advertised between networks no downtime
or manual changes to routing tables
let's walk through cloud router setup if
you remember from my last episode I had
a static route VPN setup let's create a
dynamic router for this VPN setup in
u.s. East by going to the cloud router
page here I'll give it a name select the
VPC network that contains the instances
that you want to reach choose the region
where you want to locate the cloud
router it advertises all subnets in the
region where it's located pick a Google
ASN you're not using anywhere else in
your network an ASN uniquely identifies
each network on the internet for bgp
sessions choose whether to advertise all
subnets visible to the cloud router or
create custom routes next you can add a
tunnel to each VPN gateway and establish
bgp sessions between the two cloud
routers or with your on-premise router
which you can check out in the
documentation below cloud router is the
orchestral conductor for traffic between
your on-prem and the cloud like when
using VPN and cloud interconnect it
helps a growing network continue to
function in the face of failures and
other furry rodents to support
scalability and adaptability stay tuned
for more and remember optimizing your
network means freeing up your bandwidth
you
[Music]